why the hangover part 3 oh god this film
should be dead all movie theaters should
find the film reels and burn them like
an inglorious basterds let's stop
Bradley Cooper look how bored this guy
looks this man has never looked like he
did not give a [ __ ] about anything that
was going on every single scene he was
just like what are you doing stop what
why why why am I in this movie ed Helms
apparently people got annoyed I am
freaking out so much apart too so he
tried finding that balance of freaking
out but remaining like subtle about it
he's another one who seemed like I don't
want to be here Zach Galifianakis you
know the fat guy with the beard he is
the central character I don't know why
any of these people are still hanging
out with his mother [ __ ] how can two
logical people still want to help out a
very subtle mentally challenged person
although he didn't make me laugh a
couple of times ciao remember that guy
you had a few scenes in the first one in
a couple scenes in the second one well
now he's the main character because
studios were like oh my God he's funny
Rishi just throw him in there forever he
is one of the worst things about this
movie absolutely annoying he should have
just been in doses well I don't whine
this movie is a comedy is it funny no
it's been a while since I've seen a
movie where so many people are walking
out halfway through due to no laughter
of course there's always that annoying
[ __ ] who happens to be right next to you
who's like haha this movie is more like
a thriller that has like weird jokes
every once in a while man this movie
really sucked balls one last thing I
don't know why they call us the hangover
part 3 no one gets drunk let me get
straight to the point here all in all I
have to
say the hangover part 3 really really
got it wrong all right guys they should
check it out my review for that horrible
piece of [ __ ] why don't you go ahead
spill that comment box below and tell me
what did you think of the hangover part
3 did it meet your expectations if it
did please try and convince me and if
you want to see more in-depth review of
the hangover part 3 go ahead and check
out my show they do my buddy Jerry
called reasons to see where we will not
give you reasons to see the hangover
country who will give you plenty of
reasons not to see the hangover part 3
and last but not least if you want to
get updated every time one of my reviews
is out go ahead and subscribe to my
channel by clicking on the link right
here you see it it's a pretty link isn't
it we made it a certain color that way
it's more appealing to the eyes so more
people will click on it